[Music]
some of the best food I haves in India
or Street food and every little food
store was cooking up something spicy
something delicious
Oh TSP of oil and a toast off a teaspoon
of cumin mustard seeds just a salt and
pepper lightly fry them off it's really
important to cook off the spices
intensifies the flavor but really draws
out that nice spicy deep rich flavor so
onion treating just one in front two
behind nice and fine onions in now when
i caramelize onions mustard seeds of
started to infuse cumin has that nice
kick now we're the little touch of
butter in there get it nice and sort of
rich gas up nice and high and really
cameras other than your's now once the
onions have turned a rich golden color
that's what I'm looking for that's
beautiful a baby spinach see that pan
nice and hot if you don't cook it out -
all breakfast ends up watering when the
spinach is cooked set aside and it's on
to the spicy eggs now the breakfast
really starts to come alive for nice
eggs now give those eggs a little whisk
a little touch of butter into the pan
and teaspoon of oil so the butter
doesn't burn when the butter and oil are
hot add a teaspoon of garam masala and
turmeric
could without now take your eggs into
the pan almost gonna make like a really
nice spicy scrambled egg turn the gas
down now does the scrambled egg comes
together just finish that with a little
bit of butter I quite like the sort of
creaminess makes this so much more
delicious and then from there you get my
spinach chopped up and then fold in just
finish to your scrambled egg something
quite exciting about eating spiced for
breakfast but I serve in these wonderful
little thin naan breads this will work
with any flatbread or wrap you fancy and
then lightly toasts your now take the
eggs off the heat whilst you get on with
the last job
a quick mint and spiced yogurt dressing
toddler tablespoons of fresh yogurt in
there's always something to take out the
heat then add chopped mint salt and
turmeric mix that in now take scrambled
egg and half fill and now toss smells
incredible get your yogurt down on top
then lift that over and for me that's
what really stands out with street food
in India how delicious they can make
street food a little bit of spice
[Music]
once you try this spicy rap I promise
you scrambled eggs
will never taste the same
[Music]